so we're in the basement of the Royal
Society in London this is the UK Academy
of Sciences and they have exhibitions
here telling people about interesting
things about science and so we've come
here because there's a really
interesting exhibit relevant to the work
of Lawrence who was the person after
whom the element Lorenz ium was named
after lawrencium is another one of the
elements right at the bottom of the
periodic table which are really heavy
very radioactive they fall to pieces
very rapidly so chemists are very and
physicists are very lucky if they just
make a few atoms of this so there's
nothing to tell you about the uses of
lawrencium because nobody's made enough
Lawrence seem to use it for anything
except as the subject of scientific
papers and physical measurements so
instead I want to show you here a piece
of equipment which is very similar to
the sort of equipment that Lawrence used
when he was doing his pioneering work in
Berkeley California close to San
Francisco so let's go along here
Lawrence was famous for inventing an
instrument called the cyclotron which
was were accelerating electrons to very
high speeds it was in fact the precursor
of the Large Hadron Collider which
everybody is now talking about but he
thought of it I think one day in the
light of the library in Berkeley and he
imagined to begin with an instrument
that was literally as big as my two
hands you a few inches across and his
idea was that if you made a vessel which
was quite flat and circular not very
high and put it in a big magnetic field
the electrons could go round and round
and round and be accelerated to go
faster and faster the idea was that he
made one and demonstrated the principle
and he patented it and then he built
bigger and bigger and bigger machines
and as he made them not only did the
disk
bigger but at the same time the magnet
got bigger as well and the final magnet
that he made in Berkeley which was
installed just before the Second World
War was so large that a large part of
his research group could sit between the
poles of the magnet and it's so heavy
that the magnet is still there to this
day but come and look over here this is
a cyclotron that was built in Cambridge
the first thing that strikes you is that
it doesn't look very exciting it's two
copper disks which are not actually
connected together and the voltage is
switched between one disk and the other
so as the electron goes round when it
gets to the end of one you switch the
voltage so it goes on being accelerated
and it goes round and round and as it
goes round in a magnetic field the
faster it goes the bigger the circle so
it goes round and round around in a
larger larger circle until the end it
flies out of one of these tubes I think
again that it is important to say that
some of these historic physics
experiments which are so important to
both chemistry and physics were done
with equipment that really looks
surprisingly simple and it is the really
clever ideas that have been so important
to physics and chemistry rather than
always having enormous ly complicated
apparatus sometimes to take these ideas
to their full extreme you do need
complicated apparatus but that's not the
starting point well I've read quite a
bit about he was meant to be a very
egotistical person and a real control
freak but my father-in-law worked in
Lawrence's research group when he was an
English undergraduate he was
sent to America during the Second World
War to work in Lawrence's group on the
enrichment of uranium isotopes that is
concentrating uranium-235 the less
common isotope which was basis for the
atom bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima
so John King my father-in-law worked in
the research group I don't know exactly
what he did but it's really quite a
sobering thought that during the Second
World War some of the brightest
scientists had to work on these terrible
projects really in order to save their
countries and let us hope that these
such things never happen again